I have to say the other thing that has
always impressed me is you have such
amazing style you really have fans I
mean even the Hat you're wearing right
now oh it's fantastic yeah these are fun
these are fun this is a good friend of
mine uh this guy uh James Keith the the
company is named Keith James but he you
know he came up with this red bottom hat
like a few years ago and it was me and
Floyd Mayweather we kind of jumped on
early and then everybody you know it's a
very popular hat the red bottom hat so
this is this is cool you can go and grab
it that's a very cool looking hat I
don't think I could pull it off I think
you have to be able to pull it off and
when I put a hat on I look like a child
that stole his father's hat that's what
it looks like you know what I mean it
just does
and I've got a massive head so even a
big hat looks like a yamaka on me oh
yeah which you can relate to Mr Schaefer
of course but you know it's amazing
because I'm I'm curious that was
something you were interested in even as
a as a young man as a kid you're very
interested in style yeah yeah you know
we I grew up in a um a small town in
Missouri Caruthersville Missouri but my
mother who was probably you know I guess
in her generation was one of the first
people to kind of go away to college and
then come back and so she she you know
she knew how to do the order from the
catalogs and and you know so people
would normally shop at the little local
store in town but my mother would be
like you know ordering from magazines
and so very early on I could remember
having like nice outfits when I go to
school right third fourth grade like
people would know me for my clothes and
so it's not like like today's generation
where you gotta have like the the top
thing you know like everybody like you
go you gotta have Jordans or these shoes
it's just like you just wanted to have
something different than the other kids
yeah and so I think that became you know
a part of like my identity for sure and
then coming from St Louis that was
another thing to like Midwest was a very
I remember like my family would dress up
on Saturday mornings to do nothing like
you would go by and you're like where
are you going no nowhere just
full-fledged beautiful outfits on and
that was kind of the way like people who
love to show off their clothes so so I
think I brought that to the stage uh and
it was good because I think very like
right after me the you know the kind of
jeans and t-shirt thing became very
popular and I I kind of like that I'm
not that I treat going on the stage more
like a professional yes yeah I always uh
I always like even to this day if I'm
doing if I'm on stage I like to put on a
tie and sometimes I'm wearing it with a
jean jacket but I'm wearing a tie
because I like to create the difference
between it's like if you get up at the
altar or something in church yeah you
you want to have a little bit of that
feeling of Separation that I've I'm
dressing up to go do this thing that's
very important to me and you have to
show it in very small ways
um but you know I I didn't get I didn't
realize how much clothes could influence
a person
I I had no had no clothes I was nude for
years uh but I wasn't it wasn't until I
was like in my late 20s Conan O'Brien
shrieks shrieks I kept wearing anything
I can see his veins
cover that thing up
so I was I was uh no but it's true that
I I didn't have a sense and I remembered
uh getting some important gig and going
and needing a suit and going out and
buying like a nice suit and I put it on
when I was in my late 20s before I owned
like a really nice suit and I remembered
thinking this makes me feel better about
myself oh definitely it and uh it it was
as much for me as for anybody else and I
think when you get up on stage and you
know you want to I don't know you want
to feel like you look good it helps any
any you'll take anything that will help
a little bit no definitely that's so
important I I don't think people would
like take that into account anymore like
because it's just really a world where
you can just show up with whatever you
got on and everybody's just like it's
all about the artist which is fine you
know but I I say the same thing I
remember when those like Suit Warehouse
places kind of came on you'd be like
three suits for a hundred bucks or
whatever yeah and I used to like um sell
fax machines like I used to sell uh like
uh the the RICO fax machine and I
remember having one of those suits and I
lucked up and got one like a A zenuti or
some some brand that felt like it was
like oh this is really Italian right but
I remember that particular suit made me
feel extremely aristocratic like I was
like oh the lab changed I did that laugh
actually yeah
oh guys come on
yeah anybody can get a message from you
like just put this in there
this is gonna be the thing for the next
seven decades you'll uh
the facts is never going away never
going out you're gonna leave this trust
me this you can own this forever fam
you also you saw you you were a claims
adjuster for State Farms insurance oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yep that was uh and
that was that was were you good were you
a good claims adjuster no no no let's
just get that out there and and you know
in case anyone's trying to hire you yeah
they're still in a rental car yeah you
know which is probably the kind of stuff
I would do I would just I would just
like I was I was like one of those
claims adjusters like you give me any
hard luck story I'm like okay sure that
makes sense
to the point that one year a mommy a
mommy stole your house yeah oh yeah of
course yeah I get it mommy's it's been a
rash
trust me I see it all the time I haven't
seen I got files just stacked up over
here you're good but I I definitely
people would would start to come to me
around uh prom and graduation time and
have these made up accidents so that I
can get them rental cars for their kids
to drive so you know and I knew that's
what was going on so like oh you know
somebody ran into me at the grocery
store I'm like okay got it we'll uh well
let's say that your car needs a two-day
thing and go ahead we're at the Cadillac
for the door I know what you're doing
but I was able to you know I was able to
do that for a while that was a fun that
was a fun kind of professional gig where
you did learn the you know like all the
differences between people's
personalities because car people are
exactly kind of who you think they are
like Corvette people are the super the
best if you you know you can't tell a
Corvette person anything they they drive
a Corvette yeah you're like we didn't
have Ferraris in in you know in St Louis
so that was rare if I met a Ferrari
person I would be in awe yeah to this
day I've never driven any of those fancy
cars really I've never driven a Ferrari
or a Lamborghini or a Bugatti or any of
those I don't even know what it's like
to drive one I don't know that I've been
in one yeah I've been I had a Ferrari
for uh I had a Ferrari for like maybe a
couple of months it just it kept
breaking it was weird I don't know I
felt like I had a lemon or something so
I didn't really keep that one and then I
got in a Lamborghini one time and you
know it's so low it just really wasn't
made for you know the brothers of my
girth uh so so it was quite embarrassing
it's like you pull up in a 300 300 000
car and then you got to do some kind of
drop and roll
all right
the valet is like yes yes thank you
9.8 once I put the gas in I'm waiting to
everybody else leaves before I get in
you know they should have uh tailors for
cars they should have yeah you know what
I mean like you want a Ferrari I make
you a Ferrari you know when they measure
you and then they get you that slightly
wider rounder I love Giuseppe
but of course